you know the other day I was looking at
pictures of Diddy don't ask me why but I
come to realize that [ __ ] look
like he sold his soul to the devil
sunken eyes a [ __ ] sounds a rock you the
[ __ ] devil [ __ ] can I get away with
calling Vidya [ __ ]
I don't think so cuz he ain't no [ __ ]
you up saying sorry yes dance moves I
keep doing it this is why nobody wants
to work with me except of Kevin Hart yo
[Music]
hey what is going on YouTube you miss me
you miss me yes you did I [ __ ] miss
you I haven't done one of these in a
while I like to get close because I want
you to breathe my presence I realized
that since I gained weight I'm up I'm a
loud mouth breather you ever try to post
a peaceful scene on Instagram but then
your own breathing [ __ ] it up look at
the squirrels everybody probably could
if your chest wasn't came in your lungs
you fat bit now recently or not so
recently because I haven't done this in
a minute a subscriber asked I feel like
it's always drama in my life because of
the people I kick it with every time I'm
with them it's always drama and I don't
want to lead them because I don't want
to be that type of friend oh my god I
hate drama I hate drama here's the thing
about drama if you have friends or your
sociable person in general there's what
the [ __ ] is if I throat if you have
friends or you're a sociable person in
general you can't avoid it it's
impossible however one thing that you
and I and everybody else in this world
can do to prevent this from happening is
to remove or relieve the people in your
relief like and you don't give them a
head shot no no no remove these type of
people from your life that bring this
type of drama to you on a regular basis
you may not want to hear this right now
but people that are not conducive to you
as a human being or your personal growth
you have to cut them out eventually and
I know what you're gonna say with three
more ah da da homie stole kuzu nobody
said that every time you make the right
choice it's going to be easy you're
damned dingleberry but eventually you
are gonna have to make that choice now
what exactly is that choice do I grow
with them or do they stay the same and I
allow them to weigh me down for the rest
of my life listen when I was younger I'm
pretty sure you and I were not that much
different you know except for the fact
that you're a girl well we both got
titties you know how it is but I used to
have that one person in my life you ever
have that one person in your group no
matter what the situation is
this [ __ ] gotta bring some negativity
in your happy space it [ __ ] sucks now
I've mentioned this before there's a
certain part of my life like I glorified
gangsta habits and I wanted to be a thug
so bad but but I couldn't get the gang
signs right that [ __ ] really well maybe
this was good cross that bridge mask
face sometimes it would just look like I
was playing like a baby keyboard a shame
now remember earlier when I mentioned
there's not one person in your group
that always got to start [ __ ] with
something I used to know would do back
in the day when I was trying to be all
horny [ __ ] you know say and you know
what the [ __ ] you are cuz you watch my
damn videos [ __ ] you remember you used
to make me start [ __ ] with people just
so you could fight them got a [ __ ]
[ __ ] up [ __ ] with that now clearly this
was not a person that I wanted to be in
my life but I was so dedicated to our
quote-unquote friendship that I didn't
want to be the [ __ ] from the group so
whatever he told me to do I did it and
every time my dumb ass did it it would
go down like this you down a world yeah
but only inside I was like that's right
me but the man is a Mickey Mouse sir
doesn't they I don't even know why at
that time we were even friends that's
right [ __ ] you I hope you watching this
video
I was a sob this one in the group and
you know everybody used to call me booty
treats because if I was in jail they
would pass my ass like it was Halloween
candy I was so focused on how everybody
else was gonna perceive me in this group
and I just didn't want to disappoint
them I mean I mean [ __ ] whatever I
wanted it was just all about that but in
all seriousness because I wanted to keep
these people in my life that constantly
brought me drama it always put me in bad
situations any idea how hard it is to
start [ __ ] with somebody but whisper
your cuss words just say it was that
Jesus Christ you're gonna say good
because listen eventually for me these
people that I knew growing up I had to
separate myself from them it wasn't easy
but I had to and all jokes aside they
were my friends since childhood I grew
up with them even back in the day when I
used to get bullied a lot of them stuck
up for me which is part of the reason
why I started kicking it with them in
the first place and so when it came time
for me I had to invest in my personal
growth I wanted to go to college and a
lot of them understood and some of them
didn't but I had to make that choice for
myself and even when we were drifting
and moving apart I couldn't tell you I I
[ __ ] felt like scum I felt like a
piece of [ __ ] I felt like a Chauncey ass
[ __ ] because I was
I guess in a sense I felt like I was
turning my back on people who were there
for me when I needed them the most but
what I felt that way I had to ask myself
a few please why is it wrong for me to
choose a different path that I feel is
right why do I feel I have some sort of
social responsibility to stunt my growth
in order to make these people happy and
mind you never once in my life when I
started to grow apart from these people
that I ever think that I was better than
them it's just I stopped relating to
them we couldn't have the conversations
that we used to because my mentality was
different and theirs was the same or
maybe their mentality changed and mine
was always the same when I slowly
started to grow apart from them if you
guys are curious let me tell you what
happened I became happier and eventually
I found people who wanted to grow with
me and supported me in my new endeavors
I definitely didn't move on because I
thought I was better than them because
I'm not in my heart of hearts I wanted a
lot of them to kind of come with me
but you know at that time they thought
what I was doing was stupid so it is
what it is they didn't understand what
the comedy thing was they didn't
understand why I wanted to leave
Sacramento they didn't understand any of
that [ __ ] they just thought that you
know I wanted to be something that I
wasn't when in reality I was really
chasing Who I am so these people who are
your quote/unquote friends want to grow
with you or you guys happen to just
develop together that's fantastic
but you will understand that not
everybody can do that with you it's a
hard thing to get right now I used to
fight my dad about it when I was younger
but he was right people that grew with
me I kept since day one and the people
that did it they still do what they do
they may hate me for but I don't hate
them for it at the end of the day you
are going to find out who you should
invest your time in you're 11 - and you
will be a lot happier for it
MPs [ __ ] I hope you're watching this
[ __ ] video you almost got my ass
killed so many times
[Music]